the EU and Italy have agreed a truce to
end months of a bitter row of the
countries much disputed budget for next
year extensive reforms and tax breaks
planned by its Euroskeptic government
would have put Italy on course to break
eurozone fiscal rules and that drew the
threat of sanctions from Brussels even
though several other countries are also
in the red crucially as far as Italy is
concerned country all 19 countries which
use the Euro must observe a deficit
ceiling of 3 percent of GDP but the big
but Spain Belgium Portugal and Slovenia
are among the nations
who've heard a telling-off for breaching
the rules the further big but it's
Frances big spending plans for next year
that's got Italian politicians riled
Paris is projecting a 3.2 percent
deficit for 2019
and while Rome was threatened with
sanctions the EU is signal actually
France probably won't be punished
it's that perceived discrepancy that
seen Italian leaders try to force
through their budget since day one this
is the first Italian budget the EU
doesn't like no surprise this is the
first Italian budget written in Rome and
not in Brussels economy Italian Iassogna
the Italian economy is healthy and this
is an economic move that will give Italy
the stability it needs we won't change
one comma in this document there isn't
any plan B you have to consider that we
are not gamblers that are betting on our
kids future on the rule 8 and Italian
let me pay for five start moving we
spoke to says there are positive aspects
in this new budget despite Italy
struggles with the EU some budget where
III thinks about the it's people think
about pools think about people who
suffer that the European policies during
the last years so we are very very
satisfied about it we have a European
Commission that was appointed in 2014
and nowadays we are almost in 2019 they
don't represent anymore the political
situation that was in Europe is saving a
very different approach towards Italy
and France this should be completely
unacceptable
what I mean we have nothing against in
France and we hope that the French can
do some expansion measures in order to
have a better living for the French
people we are all Europeans but we
cannot accept two standards two
different approach with two of the main
countries of Europe
you